χο συγγενείς σε σύγκριση με τις άλλες παραλιακές πόλης παραμένει ακόμε αυτό δημάρχι θεωρώ όχι
ότι καταρχάσει λά να καγια μέα στη δεν ήταν ποτέ ρτόχοε στην κίνες γιταν υ
πόλη που γεννηθείκαπο μεγαλώσαμε πολύ που ποτέ δν πέρασε να πτον μια λό μας όκι
θα κατοικήσουμε ίσως κάποια την έτηρονα καναλλά κάποοιασενδίόλι όπως ήταν στη μια πλευράν τα ροδρόμιο
ένα μεγάλον μέρος οιαλικές την άλλη μλευράν τις πολύς δεξαμένες ιγραϊρίου για γρό καυσήμον δεν
υπηρχες ζωτικό χώρος ι ανάπτυξη για επεντήσεις θεωρώ τια τελευταία χρόνια με τις κινήσεις που
έχουν γίνει με το γεγονός ου τ έχουμε καταφέρει να μετακινηθούν οι δεξαμενές με ότο
ότι προβλήθηκε νηλαρνακ θεωρώ ότι πλεον δεν είμαστε οφτε χοε συγκενίσει και ότι πλέοδικδικούμενι σότημα
το κομμάτι στην αναπτυξη μομως ανοικε ούτε ενανίον άλλον ούτε τι βαρος άλλον αλλά όχι
ένα δικούμαστεαυτήπο θα σας κάνο την απάντησαν υπουργοί την απάντηη α κόμη και ο πρόεδρος
γι αυτό για να προλάβω να μημου το εξεγληστρίσεται ιο είναι το πιο περίεργορο σφέσι
που ζήτησε κάποιος πό τον αντρέαβυρτο πιο περίεργοσφέτι μπορών από ότι μάλλον α με τηγιτώνισα
της γιατί πετούσαν τα νεγρά στο σπίτι της γιατί έκανες δημιές και μου είπε πάρχκε
νίνααν τιλέφωνο σε παρακαλομο να μην μάλλονουμε και κανα αυτό το πράγμα γιατί θεωρούσα ότι
πρόπε ταλύσεο και αυτό το και αυτό το ζήτηματο οποιο είνα μπορ πό απ αποιο
παραξεξενα πράγματα τα οποία είχα κάνει αλλά έντα ξε ένας δήμαρχος είναι υπεύθυνος απότους γάτους
που κάνουν ζημίες σε μια γειτονιά να πό τους κύλους που γαβγίζουν άχρίις αναπτύξεις καιεπενδήσεις
εκατομυρίω σε μια πολιίσως να πρέα σταματήσει όμως αυτηην οτροπία δηλαδή ένας δήμαρχος να σχολείται
από τι πρόβλημα σε μια γειτονιά από τα κλαδιά μεέχθρι για παράδειγμα μια ανεπένηση που
περιμένει την πολύ αυτό λέο πολλές φορσι ότι